and some breaking news to bring you now
and one person's died and another has
been injured after a car exploded in a
hospital car park in liverpool well
let's bring in our correspondent aisha
zaheed who's in the newsroom for us now
so aisha what more can you tell us well
we know that the incident happened
around 11 o'clock this morning outside
liverpool's women's hospital and it's
believed a car exploded in the car park
as you said we've had a statement
through from the police they have said
police immediately attended alongside
with merseyside fire and rescue service
and the north northwest regional
ambulance service unfortunately we can
confirm that one person has died and
another has been taken to hospital where
he's being treated for his injuries
which thankfully are not
life-threatening so far we understand
that the car involved was a taxi which
pulled up at the hospital shortly before
the explosion occurred work is still
going on to establish what has happened
and could take some time before we are
in a position to confirm anything we are
keeping an open mind as to what caused
the explosion but given how it happened
out of caution counter-terrorism police
are leading the investigation supported
by merseyside police now important to
note it's not believed to be a terror
attack at this point but there was a
bomb disposal unit present at the scene
you can see the image there
and police have cordoned off the area
they've closed off surrounding roads as
they continue their inquiries and their
investigation determined to determine
what exactly happened
aisha thank you very much
that is the breaking news that's just
coming into us there the one person has
died another has been injured after a
car exploded in a hospital car park in
liverpool